[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halwig die letzten 19 Uhr Nachrichten im
Jahr 2023 wie schön dass Sie dabei sind
wie auch Rudi zerne für den Sport sehr
gerne schönen guten Abend schauen wir
auf die Nachrichtenthemen dieses
silvestertags keine Entwarnung in den
Hochwassergebieten Bundeskanzler Scholz
bedankt sich in Niedersachsen bei den
Einsatzkräften Angriff auf zivile Ziele
russische Drohnen treffen auch ein Hotel
in harkiv mehrere ZDF Mitarbeiter werden
verletzt und die anderen feiern schon
mit Feuerwerk und vermutlich vielen
Hoffnungen startet die Welt nach und
nach in das neue
Jahr weiter angespannt aber erstmal
keine Verschärfung so beur teilen die
Behörden die Hochwasserlage heute erst
Dienstag und Mittwoch wird wieder
stärkerer Regen erwartet etliche
Kommunen Barten erneut auf Böllerei zu
verzichten um die Einsatzkräfte nicht
noch mehr zu belasten am stärksten
betroffen sind Teile von Sachsen Anhalt
und fast ganz Niedersachsen dorthin
reist er heute der Bundeskanzler um sich
vor Ort zu informieren auch dankte
Scholz den Helfern in fferden an der
Aller für ihren Einsatz Clemens Altmann
berichtet dieses Bild bot sich
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident Stefan
weil beim Anflug auf die Stadt perden an
der Aller vor einer Woche ist der Fluss
über seine Ufer getreten heute
informiert sich der Kanzler vor Ort über
die Lage konkrete Zusagen des Bundes
etwa für Finanzhilfen an die betroffenen
Gebiete brachte er bei seinem Besuch
nicht mit betonte aber und ich will
gerne noch mal versichern dass der Bund
mit seinen Möglichkeiten den Ländern den
Landkreisen den Bürgermeister und
Bürgermeister allen die vor Ort tätig
sind zur Verfügung steht ausdrücklich
betont der Kanzler die Hilfsbereitschaft
und den Zusammenhalt in Zeiten der Krise
was er meint zeigen diese Bilder einer
Menschenkette 200 km westlich in Haren
an der Ems einem Aufruf über Social
Media Folgen beinah 1000 Helfer bis in
den Abend hinein laufen die Sandsäcke
von Hand zu Hand bis an den Fluss um den
brüchigen Deich zu
verstärken die Hochwasserlage vor allen
im Norden Deutschlands bleibt angespannt
wir wissen genau diese Situation dieses
Risiko diese gefahranlage ist noch nicht
vorbei wir müssen immer noch sehr
vorsichtig sein überall haben wir
Deichläufer die unterwegs sind und
schauen dass die deicher halten für die
Silvesternacht sind neue Schauer
angekündigt die auch die
niedersächsischen Überschwemmungsgebiete
treffen
könnten auch in seiner Neujahrsansprache
versuchte der Bundeskanzler Zuversicht
zu verbreiten gemeinsam kämen wir auch
mit Gegenwind zurecht sagte er die Welt
sei rauer geworden aber man solle sich
erinnern viele Befürchtungen in
Deutschland wie z.B Stromausfälle und
kalte Wohnungen sein nicht eingetreten
klaus brotbeck hat mehr der Kanzler zum
Ende eines bewegten Jahres voll von
Krieg von Krisen und drohenden
Katastrophen wie gerade dem Hochwasser
in Deutschland die Welt sei im Umbruch
atberaubben
schnell auch wir müssen uns deshalb
verändern vielen von uns bereitet das
sorgen bei einigen sorgt das auch für
Unzufriedenheit ich nehme mir das zu
Herzen und zugleich weiß ich wir in
Deutschland kommen dadurch Deutschland Z
Scholz müsse jetzt in seine Zukunft
investieren in Infrastruktur und
Klimaschutz und in moderne Arbeitsplätze
zugleich würden diejenigen spürbar
entlastet die das Land am Laufen halten
von morgen an Zahlen Arbeitnehmern und
Arbeitnehmer in Deutschland 15
Milliarden Euro weniger an Steuern eine
vierköpfige Familie mit einem normalen
Einkommen hat dadurch im nächsten Jahr
mehr als 500 € zusätzlich zur Verfügung
liebe Mitbürger und Mitbürger uns macht
auch die Einsicht stark dass jede und
jeder gebraucht wird in unserem Land
wenn wir uns das klar machen wenn wir
uns gegenseitig mit diesem Respekt
begegnen dann brauchen wir keine Angst
zu haben vor der Zukunft deswegen wirb
der Kanzler für offene Diskussionen und
faere Kompromisse selbst wenn er so
Scholz auf manch laute Debatte des
vergangenen Jahres gut hätte verzichten
können 7 Minuten lang ist die Rede des
Bundeskanzlers zu sehen direkt nach
diesen Nachrichten oder jederzeit in
unserer
Mediathek seit Tagen bombardiert
Russland wieder massiv die Ukraine
gestern vor allem die Stadt harkev im
Osten des Landes dabei wurden neben
Wohngebäuden und kaffés auch ein Hotel
getroffen in dem viele Journalisten
wohnten ZDF Chefredakteurin Bettina en
spricht von einem weiteren Angriff
Russlands auf die freie Presse auch
unsere Reporterin Alisa jung war mit
ihrem Team in dem Hotel hier ihr
Bericht es ist einen Tag vor dem
Silvesterfest als es um 19 Uhr am
Samstagabend einen unfassbaren schlagput
das Gebäude bebt Russland greift erneut
die Ukraine an und trifft dabei das
rakif Palace Hotel und damit auch unser
zdfteam drei von uns im fünften Stock
eine Kollegin in der Lobby und ein
Kollege im Elfen Stock wir dachten hier
sind wir sicher es gibt einen Bunker
aber es gibt keinen sicheren Ort in der
Ukraine unsere ukrainische Übersetzerin
wird von Trümmerteilen in der Lobby
schwer verletzt und im Krankenhaus
versorgt der Kollege im Elfen Stock hat
wie durch ein Wunder überlebt und wieder
zielt Russland auf Zivilisten und
diesmal trifft es auch uns in unserem
Hotel in hakiv es ist nicht das erste
Mal dass gezielt Hotels angegriffen
werden wo Journalisten und NGO
Mitarbeiter schlafen als wir das Gebäude
nach Ende des luftalarms verlassen sehen
wir Teile der Rakete und das Loch das
sie gerissen hat insgesamt waren nach
Aussage der Hotelmanagerin 15 Zimmer
vermietet mindestens zehn davon an
Journalisten als wir die Innenstadt
verlassen schickt Russland mehrere
drohen ins Stadtzentrum von
rakiv wir hören sie auf unserem Weg raus
aus der Innenstadt sie zielen auf
Wohngebäude kaffés ein weiteres Mal
zeigt
Russland führt einen Krieg gegen
Zivilisten jetzt zum Krieg im Nahen
Osten israel hat nach eigenen Angaben
das Hauptquartier der islamistischen
Hamas im Süden des Gazastreifens
gestürmt in dem Komplex in chanjunes
soll die Geheimdienstzentrale der Hamas
gewesen sein das Militär setzte auch
heute die Bombardierungen fort die
Angriffe konzentrierten sich auf Ziele
im mittleren und südlichen Teil von Gaza
dabei wurden laut palästinensischer
Gesundheitsbehörde in den letzten 24
Stunden 150 Menschen
getötet der Krieg im Nahen Osten erhöht
auch die Terrorgefahr in Deutschland in
Nordrheinwestfalen wurden jetzt drei
weitere Verdächtige festgenommen
offenbar mit islamistischem Hintergrund
die Polizeiaktion steht im Zusammenhang
mit den Terrorwarnungen für den Kölner
Dom dort gelten schon seit Weihnachten
massive
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen laut Polizei gab
es Hinweise dass ein Anschlag mit einem
Auto am Dom geplant
war fragen wir Thomas münten in
Düsseldorf wie konkret war dieser Plan
und wie groß ist die Gefahr heute an
Silvester es muss wohl sehr konkret
gewesen sein gestern Abend ganz spät kam
der Hinweis vom Bundeskriminalamt an die
Kölner Polizei jetzt könnte man
natürlich sagen ein Auto auf den Kölner
Dom der liegt in mitten einer
Fußgängerzone das stimmt aber so nicht
denn unter dem kölnerd befindet sich
eine große Tiefgarage mit zwei
Stockwerken und da mussten alle
Fahrzeuge überprüft werden das ist
gestern geschehen heute ist jeder der
rein und raus fahren wollte kontrolliert
worden und im Moment sagt die Polizei
besteht keine größere Gefahr sie hat
allerdings die einsatzkäfte rund um den
Kölner Dom massiv verstärkt es sind wohl
geschätzt noch mal 1000 Polizisten mehr
im Einsatz
ich sage mal der Innenminister des
Landes nordwestfahen hat gesagt heute
Abend ist der Kölner Dom sicher und das
wird die Polizei auf jeden Fall
gewährleisten sodass man im Moment sagen
konkret gibt es keine Gefahr ich würde
allerdings nicht in die Kölner
Innenstadt gehen danke schön Thomas
münten aus
Düsseldorf dazu kommt immer noch die
Sorge vor Krawallen in dieser
Silvesternacht in Berlin stehen deshalb
tausende von Einsatzkräften bereit nach
Ausschreitungen beim vergangenen
Jahreswechsel werden heute 4000 Beamte
im Einsatz sein dazu kommen noch 500
Bundespolizisten an den Bahnhöfen eine
proalästinensische im Stadteil Neuköln
wurde verboten vor dem Brandenburger Tor
steigt traditionell die große Silvester
Party und genau da schauen wir jetzt hin
zu Andrea kieel und Johannes B Kner die
das ganze heute Abend moderieren was
habt ihr vorbereitet schon mit guter
Laune auf jeden
Fall hallo liebe Barbara hallo liebe
Zuschauer es ist überragend wir sind
nicht mehr allein Achtung Hall
das sind viele 10000 Menschen die sich
schon jetzt zu diesem frühen Zeitpunkt
am Brandenburger Tor versammelt haben
die dabei sein wollen wenn ab 20:15 Uhr
hier im ZF die große Silvester Party
startet einzige live Party im deutschen
Fernsehen die größte silvesterpy Europas
zu Fuße des Brandenburger Tors was von
den Künstlerinnen und Künstlern von
Festival of Lights zauberhaft in Szene
gesetzt wird über den ganzen Abend und
musikalisch ist wirklich für jeden was
dabei von
über bis zu chr nor von SM also Party
pur am Brandenburger Tor und ich bin
sicher es werden fast 100000 Menschen
sein die Live hier in Berlin mit dabei
sind Gäste aus Berlin aus Europa und aus
aller Welt die größte Silvester Show
Europas live im ZF
R geht's los mit
johannesner wir kriegen sie wir kriegen
sie no
ges ganz vielen Dank guten rutschuch
auch es glitzert und leuchtet ganz
wunderbar da schon in Berlin und auf der
anderen Seite der Erde haben die
Menschen den Jahreswechsel längst hinter
sich gebracht einige Metropolen übrigens
auch ganz ohne Feuerwerk wie Thomas
gonsor
zeigt Happy New Year das neue Jahr in
Neuseeland ist es längst da 12 Uhr
mittags unserer Zeit startet die Show in
Auckland Feuerfontänen aus dem Sky Tower
aus 300 m in den Himmel ein hoch hoch
auf
2024 2 Stunden später Australien Sydney
strahlt Hafen Opernhaus Kulisse fürs
weltweit wohl opulenteste
pyrotechniktheater erstmals gibt hier
zusätzlich KI gesteuerte
Lichtprojektionen Lärm Luftverschmutzung
sind reduziert weniger Schall und Rauch
Klimaschutz in Knall
Bund traditionell anders
Japan Glockenschläge 108 mal das steht
für die Einheit von allem mit innerer
Einkehr in die Zukunft einer aus den
Fugen geratenen Welt vor zwei Stunden
Hong Kong feiern im Farbenrausch sicher
auch hier voller Hoffnung dass rund um
den Globus der Frieden siegt
2024 neue Chancen neues
[Musik]
Glück die große Frage innere Einkehr
oder Party heute abend nee mit dem
Freiern werden die Skispringer ich denke
du BST auf die Skispringer ne elich von
dir aber nee ne komm auf die Skispringer
zu zweit zu zweit ist auch schön also
die schiefbringer Wellinger ist unser
Tipp für die nächsten Tage ne genau also
mit dem freierern wird er sich
zurückhalten aber Andreas Wellinger ist
schon mal glänzend in die zweite Station
der vierchanzen Turnier gestartet in der
Qualifikation zum Neujahrsspringen in
gamischparten Kirchen wurde der Sieger
von Oberdorf zweiter den besten Sprung
präsentierte der Slowene anche
lanisek
ein Highlight für den Nachwuchs und ein
spezielles Aufwärmprogramm für die
Weltelite weil der Fahrstuhl der
olympichanze streikt muss auch Wellinger
perpedes zum Abflug der klingt dann
allerdings perfekt und endet mit der
Tagesbestweite von
139 m aber ohne Telemark wenn da hinter
der ein leichten Schlenker macht dann
sitz wir gern hinten ab und das ist der
Fehler den muss ich morgen definitiv
besser machen weil da sind wir jetzt mal
fünf Punkte verloren gegangen aufgrund
der besseren Haltungsnoten gewinnt der
Slowene anche lanisek mit 134 m die
Qualifikation die podesspringer von
Obersdorf Kobayashi und Kraft landen nur
auf den Plätzen 17 und 6 während
Wellinger seine Topform eindrucksvoll
bestätigt skiangläuferin Victoria karl
ist bei der zweiten Etappe der Tour Desi
Zweite geworden in Toblach war die Team
olympiiegerin über 10 km im klassischen
Stil mit einer starken Leistung aufs
Podest gestürmt Katharina hennich
erreichte einen respektablen fünften
Platz der Tagessieg ging an die finin
kertu niskanen bei den Männern war
Friedrich moch als Siebter bester
Deutscher und der 16-Jährige Engländer
Luke Littler eilt bei der darz WM in
London von Sieg zu Sieg jetzt gelang ihm
der nächste große Wurf im Achtelfinale
setzte er sich gegen den 40 Jahre
älteren exweltmeister V bnefeld aus den
Niederlanden mit 4 Z1 durch nach den
bisherigen Siegen belohnte sich ller
stets mit einem Döner so gesehen sind
noch drei Döner bis zum
Titel was auch immer du heute Abend ist
Döner nicht die vier schanzenournee
willst du uns nicht mehr ach so die
wollte got morgen ab 13:45 Uhr die
vierchanzene Live IMF jetzt haben wir
aber auch noch kurz der Blick aufs
neujahrswetter das wird wechselhaft mit
vielen Wolken etwas Sonne und ein paar
Schauern im Süden und anfangs auch im
Osten ist es freundlicher und trocken
das ganze bei 4 bis
11° das war's von uns für dieses Jahr im
Namen des gesamten Teams bedanke ich
mich sehr herzlich für Ihr Interesse und
Ihr Vertrauen und wünsche Ihnen alles
Gute für
2024 hier jetzt geht's weiter mit dem
Bundeskanzler und wir sehen uns morgen
wenn Sie mögen einen schönen
Silvesterabend
noch
[Musik]
ه